[Music]
actor and comedian
cedric the entertainer has been making
audiences laugh for more than three
decades and he's still going strong he's
appeared in dozens of hit films and
shows including
the steve harvey show the original kings
of comedy and the barbershop franchise
cedric the entertainer currently starts
as calvin butler on the cbs series and
neighborhood i'm laughing because this
show is
hilarious it explores what happens when
a white family from the midwest
moves next door to a black family in los
angeles in this clip from tonight's
season premiere calvin talks with his
son
after a member of their community
becomes a victim of racial injustice
i'm angry every time another racist cop
kills one of us out there
or every time the system fails us it
makes me want to burn it all down
but that's not the answer well then what
it is
because they are not listening to us so
what the hell am i supposed to do you
supposed to use your hand man come on
man you got to fight smart
all right you got to organize got to
talk to your people you got to get them
to listen
look they want you to fight with this
but you got to fight with this
so true man cedric the entertainer joins
us now cedric welcome back
congrats on your third season let's talk
about tonight's episode i watched it
yesterday and
listen it's a comedy show and you took a
serious tone
and it worked you were able to infuse
comedy in something that's very
serious how did this come about you said
you used a lot of your own life personal
experiences
really powerful episodes so bravo to you
oh thank you so much you know the show
creator jim reynolds my executive
producer partner on the show
uh after you know we were coming back
for season three we thought it was
important to talk about some of the big
issues that were happening be it
the pandemic or or you know of course
the social injustice that went
on throughout most of the summer and you
know
and we just deemed that it was just the
most important kind of point of view to
have a voice
in that because we represent a fictional
neighborhood
in los angeles but these things were
real all throughout los
angeles during the summers uh as you
know through the george floyd and the
brianna taylor of it all and you know
our own cases out here in california so
uh we just felt like it was important to
say something and we tried to do that
and knew that
we are a you know 30 minute sitcom so we
try to make you laugh as well
i thought it was interesting the
reaction of your neighbors compared to
what was happening in your house i could
see a lot of people having this exact
conversation
that you were having with the neighbors
that's what i thought was so genius
about what you did
yeah you know that was the other thing
you know because when when you have
these kind of
you know uprisings when the people
started to come together and this was
something
uh you know again throughout the george
floyd of it all we hadn't seen
any you know kind of galvanizing of
people uh
to a cause at least you know before
since civil rights or whatever
and so it was just very important to try
to get that point of view where they had
some now he would tell you about things
that were going on
and and you know so that you can allow
one to
just empathize with the circumstances
just be able to empathize with it right
yeah cedric we were talking at the table
before that that how much
we all love sitcoms and especially now
they seem to be comforting in a certain
way and i'm wondering
how you're approaching this i mean
you're shooting you used to have a live
audience i don't think you probably have
one right now
you're also you're also used to stand up
and you love the feedback of a live
audience how are you approaching this
with everything that's going on
you know i mean of course it's a unique
time to do anything so
all of us who are even just really
blessed to be able to get back to work
or just thankful for that part of it
alone
and so you know the main thing is that
we
as the actors on the stage we have to
kind of follow all these protocols and
make sure that we
are doing the right things just to be at
work and then uh
it is different you know i haven't gone
out on the road in eight months so
i don't know what it is to be in front
of a live audience i'm gonna be rusty
they don't tell them what these jokes
gonna be girls they'll be like hey
yeah right i'll be like oh i ain't
finished sticking that one all the way
through
y'all but uh okay let's try this next
one
i know but cedric you're also doing the
funny video show i think that's great
but to anthony's point how are you able
you are a professional entertainer
how are you able to maintain your humor
during this time and i think anthony
really hit on something because i find i
found myself laughing at the show and
how much i crave that
yeah you know i mean you're right and i
think the real you know the real
key is that with the show that we do
have
uh we have some people that's uh like
they play the background or they do the
uh the stand-ins for us when we're uh
switching clothes or any
things for the camera people and they
they're also now hired to laugh
and so you know they have to laugh
do they get paid extra for that yeah do
they get paid for laughing
they actually it is a union job
so all you all you kids out there
studying your
your physics and psychics hey you could
just be a laugher
yeah doing all that that's what you do
today
just go to the entertainers laugh
institute
you're you're a lot listen you make us
laugh i always say comedy is another
form of intelligence it's not easy to be
a comedian and you do it so well
cheering you on always congratulations
cedric thank you for getting up
thank you so much thanks oh indeed thank
you guys so much appreciate it
tonight everybody all right done and
done
season three of the neighborhood airs
tonight at 8 7 central right here on cbs